[Music]
[Applause]
guess who is retiring they're going to
sign a one-day contract with san
francisco hall of famer
although
that doesn't come to mind when i say his
name surefire hall of famer ah yeah
yeah one day
one day contract
uh
he played in i think five pro bowls
a third round draft pick
and this will give it away
he ended his career with exactly
16 000 rushing yards
franklin gore yes
yeah
so he's behind emmitt smith and walter
payton
frank gore ended with 16 000 yards right
at 16 000.
that's great though can you imagine if
it's 15 999 i'd have to get one more
carry there that one-day contract yeah
yeah one-day contract reggie miller hall
of famer turner's sports nba analyst
joining us on the program
reg how are you
i'm doing great first of all hold on
paulie did you just say in question
first ballot hall of famer 16 000 yards
seriously paulie
yes
first ballot easy would that be like an
nba player averaging 16 points a game
for 20 years
or is that better than that
he he's in
if you averaged 16 points for 20 years
yeah you should be in the hall of fame
consistency
really
is joe johnson a hall of famer
no but he didn't have her 16 points for
20 years well but he averaged what
what's joe johnson averaged for how many
years
16 years
17 years no no way he ever 16 points for
16 years all right what do you got
paulie joe johnson in 20 nba seasons
average exactly 16 points per game
hold up hold up no no no no no
but he's been in and out of the league
those 20 years like he signed with
boston
as like a
arcovid replacement and he stayed on but
he's averaging 16 points for 20 years
you didn't average 20 every year
no but i averaged 19.999
for 18.
hold up i want to get
to some housekeeping first okay
before we preview okay um the finals
okay number one i've known you
theodore for over 25 years yeah close to
30 years yeah and fritzy you've been a
big part of that so congratulations on
that because i know it's the 20-year
anniversary of youtube fritzy you've
been a big big huge part of that so
that is awesome um and i want to go back
to game seven
of that boston versus miami series
theodore you want to do the jimmy butler
shot
yes because i've been
reading stuff on twitter looking at the
you know the sports radio pundits talk
and okay i've been growing angry at this
so please interject all you want i'm
going to give you the psychology of what
goes into
that shot and why jimmy butler took that
three as opposed to maybe driving
getting fouled or scoring e2
to tie it and potentially take it to
overtime right
as a scorer a leader
they're in they're only in that position
because of jimmy butler agree or
disagree yeah i agree okay
they were down 15 points they had scored
13 points in a matter of a minute and a
half to close within two so they were
completely gassed just to get into
that ball game now if i'm jimmy butler i
am assessing this in real time by the
way because i'm the man
i've got to
look at the eyes of my teammates do i
think we have enough if this was to go
into overtime now remember
you're processing information like this
and
when he gets the ball the rebound and he
goes coast to coast this is what he's
thinking i easily probably could have
drove on al horford who's a great
defender who's been an all-nba defender
who can guard shooting guards and point
guards
or
i could pull up for this three
potentially go up one
and put the pressure on them to score or
whatever to take the lead
for people who have never laced up a
shoe bounced the ball for them to say
that's a bad shot
it just lets you know
what idiots they are
you now again i will say this at home
most of the time you go for a tie
and take it to overtime and let the
crowd
that will kind of fuel you
but
in this particular instance the heat had
expended so much energy just to get back
in the ball game
i'm just thinking personally there's no
way they would have had enough
to hold off boston if it was to go to
overtime if he would have scored two
points got fouled and they would have
went to overtime i don't think they
would have won that game in overtime
you go for the kill shot when you have
the moment the kill shot was the three
it was a clear three and i know his
statistics aren't great
but i would live and die with kevin
durant lebron james jimmy butler stephen
curry clay thompson
whomever jason tatum jalen brown
i would live and die with those guys
taking a kill shot knowing all the
circumstances
that i just kind of told you
that's why i think that's a great shot
for for people to say that was a bad
shot it
you got to
assess everything in real time as it's
going people don't understand that and
the pressure that goes into that i
thought and think that was a great
decision by jimmy butler go for the kill
shot because you had nothing left if you
miss it we know they're on vacation
right now if you make it we're setting
up a preview of them versus golden state
in the finals
that's my take on it
being in that position over a bajillion
times 19.9 points over 18 years theodore
that's why i come up with that point and
look exactly you've been in the moment
so you speak from experience but i
wanted you taking the shot
with jimmy butler
he can beat al horford off the dribble
if you get a pull-up jumper you're gonna
see you're gonna get that shot off i
thought jimmy butler was gonna do a
hesitation blow by him
now it's tied celtics call a timeout
crowd's going crazy let's go over here
let's get ready you know we're going to
put the pressure on them if he misses
the shot then it's over i thought it
extended just a little bit now i'm going
to put pressure on a rookie coach in the
moment is jason tatum going to step up
who's going to step up and if we don't
we go into overtime
on our home floor we'll get some energy
from the fans
jimmy looked good with the shot as well
reg like it wasn't an awkward shot it
wasn't no and he had space to shoot it
yes he did all valid points you set up
my only thing is when you say blow by al
horford al's backing up he's on his
heels
daniel
al horford is a great defense he's on
his heels he's backing up he's on an
island jimmy butler is going to blow by
which is why it was a
walk in three it was a walk in three
four for jimmy butler i i get your valid
takes but i don't think they had enough
in the tank if he gets by blows by al
for al horford ties it up or gets fouled
makes two free throws and they go to
overtime i don't think the juice of that
building because they were a one-man
band the last two games they really were
and it was all including butler
lowry lowry played well yes the last two
games yes yeah but you're right i mean
that that team
healthy
gets to the finals in my opinion i agree
but you know i bam out of bio is a guy
why are we always surprised when bam out
of bio has a good game like we're like
hey bam went for 26 and nine he should
be going for these numbers thank you
duncan robinson where are you
yeah well duncan robinson it was out
though it was all about max troops he
duncan robinson never played at all i
think the second half of the season
crazy
should they have reviewed that
three-pointer by strews
did his feet actually touch it i thought
he he pulled a sean elliott i thought he
was hovering over it
look that's the age of well they had to
see enough to overturn it but my problem
is there has to be a time limit on when
you can review something i agree i think
too much time had gone by yeah because
there were so many possessions they went
to timeout and when they came out of
time out van gundy was explaining whoa
that's a big play they took that three
off by streuse
i mean things like that matter in the
big picture when it comes down to
closing time
we're talking to reggie miller uh much
has been made of the warriors experience
or the celtics lack thereof getting into
the nba finals and the point i've made
is
you know you had two rookie coaches who
beat the warriors
ty lue did and nick nurse did
and udoka is a rookie coach so
like does it not factor in with the
coach but it does with the players as
far as experience or lack there it's not
like you're playing on a neutral site
you're in march madness and you go oh
we're playing in uh the metrodome we've
never played here now i'm worried about
the shooting background they played
golden state they've been in that
building before um
like what is it about you get into an
nba finals was it that much different
for you and did experience or lack
thereof hurt you guys
experience always matters and it helps
especially the later a series goes as
for coaches and i think you and i have
talked about this many times before
head coaches in coaching in general only
matters this time of year in
professional ranks in professional
basketball
because it's
game by game adjustments
and you really can see who can coach and
who can't
and
it will matter the longer this warriors
celtics series goes um
but i kind of somewhat hearken back if
you're talking about a rookie coach in
imei udoka
let's just set up where he is now
they play hard the last game of the year
to get that number two spot where
milwaukee could have played and got that
number two spot and had home court
advantage and we'll fast forward to that
so they say okay we'll take the number
two spot and have to face brooklyn when
everyone was like oh no one wants to
play brooklyn uh kevin durant kyrie no
one wants to see the brooklyn nets what
do they do they sweep them oh up next
the world champs oh well that's
different from uh
the brooklyn and kd you got janna's
coming in here
down 3-2
have to go to milwaukee
and win a game on the road
they do that come home and blow out the
world champs in the second half
to defeat milwaukee and then you've got
the number one seed probably the hardest
working organization culture wise
in miami
and they dust them off
that's why at this point
i'm taking the rookie chains off of imei
udoka because are you picking boston
here's the problem i have in my
household theodore
my son's favorite player
is stephen curry
and it's everything around here is
warriors staff is that staff staff
i'm yelling at him to stop in the
backyard stop shooting 30 footers
poppy you're not stepping
curry he got a chance to meet steph for
the first time at all-star weekend and
it was the thrill of his life so in this
household
we're you know we him
it's the warriors we're pulling for the
worst but my fiber everything is having
me
point towards
boston and winning this in seven it
really does because well you can say it
to me your son is at school so he's not
hearing that
you're good
like this is this is a safe space right
here this is it okay
i really do believe boston's gonna win
this okay
all right don't don't tell riker don't
tell anyone else this is between the
danettes okay or and just us all right
boston is gonna win the series
what if your son said dad who's a better
shooter you or steph curry
i would tell him
okay
we're told never to lie to our children
right
okay
charles barkley was on yesterday and he
said you should work with russell
westbrook
could you make russ a better shooter
uh i could work on his
repetition but i think russ is who russ
is
at this point in his career but what is
the flaw in that jumper
i don't think there's a lot of
follow-through i think his mechanics are
wrong i think he holds the basketball
in awkward
positions but that's okay because that's
how he shoots i always tell people you
shoot how you're going to shoot i had an
awkward release
that's just they're like fingerprints
that's who you are i would yeah but you
made those he doesn't make them
therefore
i would work more on his repetition i
don't think he puts an enough time in
his shooting truthfully i think he
shoots up to a certain point where he
feels good and that's it you've got to
shoot until you are exhausted and then
that's when the shooting starts yeah
that's when the shooting starts is when
your path exhausts you
yeah i just wonder
that
you can't change him you can't and he is
who he is and that's okay i would just
want to build on him being more
consistent
and having i just don't think he has
confidence
i really don't i don't think he has
confidence in his shooting ability and
that's why i would want to work on
getting him past exhaustion because he
works so hard doing everything else in
his game rebound
playing hard defense
he works hard on everything else
that's where i want to get him so when
he is exhausted from doing everything
else in a ball game
he can rely on making a 15 18
20 foot jump shot
we suggest that charles should work with
zion
that would be awesome because moses
malone changed charles barkley's life
yes he said you're fat and you're lazy
yeah charles words and he lost 50 pounds
and it changed charles life
and the first valid hall of famer and a
top i know they said 75 players but
charles is in a top
30 type player at 6'4 being able to do
what he people want to sleep and they
just think about his mouth on tnt and
they forget about the basketball player
but he was problems
and that would be
that would be a great
if if those two could work because
charles would be brutally honest with
zion because
it's not go not only is it going to be
on the basketball court it's going to be
what's going on in the kitchen too
right like what are you putting in your
mouth yeah like how your everyday
24-hour behaviors too
and charles would be the first to tell
you he wasn't you know a role model and
he didn't do things by the book
but
what charles did know how to do was
dominate
and after he lost those 50 60 pounds
from that slight suggestion from moses
there's a reason why he was a surefire
hall of famer
yeah i i don't know
you know it's hard because back then if
i gave you money i might make a
30 million or 25 million dollar mistake
if i give you 250 million now
he
look i would you extend zion and give
him the full extent
we've had this conversation before um
there's no middle ground reg there is i
know and here's the thing
he's played 85 games over three seasons
85
so that he
the numbers are there that
he's not going to be healthy but but in
being played 60 in the first three years
philadelphia was patient with somebody
who had back
and new orleans has been patient too
but new orleans is ready to win now
that's a good young team
and i think you have to i think you have
to give them that
and i'm i never want to get in anyone
else's pockets
because we know the owners are making
10 times more if they want to pay him
250 million
the owners are making and the
organization is making a lot of money
but it is a small market and to commit
to something like that
to a guy who's only played 85 games over
three seasons is a lot theodore
but
i think he has them
he ha he has them over a barrel he does
unfortunately before i let you go i made
a big deal about boston
built this team
uh you know they signed some guy brought
some guys in but a lot of draft picks
golden state same way they built it
um
you start to look at these
big free agents and money that's spent
and we're going to bring in this guy and
bring in that guy and
it hasn't worked for the most part i
mean anthony davis getting traded to the
lakers
it it's easy we're a copycat league
where you go okay that's how you build a
franchise here
is this just an anomaly that these two
teams meeting for the championship
you know are homegrown teams
no because you've got to look at
upper echelon leadership
brad stevens who was the coach and now
is the general manager president and bob
myers
um a former agent who's used to scouting
and evaluating talent
as well as brad stevens coming from
butler and knowing how to go out and uh
recruit young players and knowing the
character
how things fit in our system
um
both of these organizations kind of
parallel one another and
um it's kudos to them because it's easy
to go out and
give a blank check to a free agent and
say they're gonna change the franchise
change the fortunes of our franchise
it's not that easy you've got to look at
character
culture of your franchise your fan base
what type of player you're bringing in
what were some of their statistics while
they were at other places
all those things have to factor in and i
applaud organizations that build from
within it's easy to go out and get the
splashy free agent and golden state kind
of did that to a certain degree bringing
in kd but they had already won they
already won a championship they had won
72 games when they brought in
kd
so that they had already built what
their culture was about and he just fit
in perfectly so i applaud teams that are
building from within because that's the
only way you you're really going to win
with players now that are 19 20 21
because you don't know how they're going
to pan out for your door celtics fans
they get a little sensitive about the
number of titles they've won number of
titles the lakers have won and that you
shouldn't include the minneapolis lakers
in the titles for the los angeles lakers
here's a guy here's a guy who would
would die for one
who cares
are you kidding me stop it
stop it you're in the finals be happy
and you have a chance to go one up on
the lakers you have a chance
don't let me down but listen boston fans
thank you don't tell my son and i'm not
going to tell your son i'm not going to
tell you no one i might tell him
i might tell your wife
but i won't tell your son
that little guy would be devastated if
you said daddy pick the celtics
these are i'm gonna be do we have one
minute is he there
yes we have 30 seconds yeah
oh no reg's going to go get his son
this is tv debut
his son's probably a better shooter
though he'll leave out probably
i know his son's probably a better
shooter than some of us in this room
uh oh
oh
okay
who do you think is gonna win between
boston and golden state
i think golden state's going to win
and why
because they're a good team
and who's your favorite who's your
favorite player
steph
curry is steph curry a better basketball
player than your dad
we raise them to tell the truth i like
that
i like that
thank god you look like your mother
thank god right yes yes
all right go work on your jumper by the
way
yes layups tell them labs and work yeah
stop shooting the three get some layups
mid-range jumpers all right
talk to you i'll talk to you next week
thank you theodore that's reggie
aloysius miller and his son